yeah welcome to this video playing the
Blitz game here against the naval King
from the US I guess yeah this is a frost
layer a blitz game after a long break
due to my holiday it's been away for
three weeks and I haven't played any
chest during my holiday which was not
planned I wanted to play a tournament in
Austria in fact playing the same event
that I have played in 2013 and actually
won but it wasn't wasn't meant to be the
problem was that the the hotel that I
intended to take there was so terrible
that it wasn't possible that what soon
it wasn't possible to use that and on
short notice I didn't get any decent
replacement and well so I decided to to
just skip this tournament and just have
a good a good time in the holidays
without any chess which wasn't so bad at
all just for a while not I'm not doing
any serious work on the game or playing
okay so we have a greenhorn opening him
trump off scheme could play Bishop d6
here to simplify matters you know maybe
the e5 Bishop is slightly annoying let's
do that yeah he just said he does not
really have a good control over 85 if I
can always challenge this piece I'm
curious what I'm able to do in this game
I really haven't played any blitz chess
for more than three weeks I also didn't
do a warm-up game I just wanted to get
things going here okay he can take or I
can retreat to our three but yeah both
does not look very promising f4
yeah just I just take like win g5 and
wind 85 pawn so he basically needed to
do what he played mighty I don't have
any problems I can put the bishop on c6
and then think about playing if I if I
have an extra pawn in the center here
and the typical problem of many
Greenpoint openings with the pawn on e6
the bishop on c8 it's nothing serious
him young should it seems he wants to
play a form so it's not much I can do
about it nothing to to fear but okay
maybe some more preparation
yeah with Queen c2 he might win the
tempo here on on the kingside player
prophylactic move against that it's
useful anyway for the back rank okay
yeah this was to be expected however I
can take now and maybe play play rook to
e8 is there any point in playing rook e8
I was like I guess I should take and
then look at the eight gaining a tempo
on the Queen yeah I'm slightly ahead in
the fight for the D foul
yeah I guess I'm going to take if it
takes with the Queen a fruity - and here
we are look d7 yeah it's difficult to to
play for for something substantial in
this position hmm Queen g5 intending
rock tea - I'll look t5 yeah look - you
won rook b8 okay I can try that maybe
play that so I have Queen d7 if
necessary
yeah moves like religion before yeah now
would lead to an isolated queen fall
position that white probably does not
want to have maybe you should just take
I'll look back to the ones also also
possible the locus is not really doing
much on the fourth ring anyway okay he
decides to allow the size allow the
isolated Queen phone he now must take
with the rook yep so let's see is there
something I can do here this general
speaking is not much maybe here
combining Queen d4 with Queen e1 and
it's an active move anyway but yeah this
is this as possible
yeah if I take the key and ponen came
suddenly should be somewhat better for
me I mean but I don't think it it should
should be a win yeah but what what do I
do with the Queen's Own probably not
much anyway yeah I probably be fine
I have fixing the the pawns no one the
king of AI is very quick here I came
coming to 2d3 you would still have the
isolated Queen phone after King d6 and C
for now you should play c4 I guess I
didn't time warning
hmm and this I'm not not terribly sure
about I always have this threat to come
to to come to safe form
okay
if we then I like a tempo at the
sublight terribly I should have played
h4 I really should have played h4
what didn't I do that
should have played h5h voice what's
really bad and this is check sure what
he's doing here
check check check check check check
checkmate yeah this was a suicidal
mission at the end maybe you wanted to
win on time or anything I don't know I'm
terrible really
I should have played each Friday sorry
this was also wrong I should have played
h5h for him if I if I go age 4 I might
still have some chances he 386 ok yes
got a for him I thought he's now forced
to move the King after which I'm winning
but he's got this evil move this this
saves the day I cannot take maybe I can
try for draw I mean
Jack I can block here now this is a draw
but he must play form this means that
it's it's not winning in any case maybe
h5s also what's so wrong I overlooked a
for this was the problem maybe I can do
something else here like age six
computer wants to play age 6 cm not 100%
sure what what to make of the end game
and I'm very sure that what one should
play here and just make it draw this is
probably it wrong but ok played this
stuff computer wants to go age six
well that's very very tricky at age four
maybe what now keeping the tempo game
alive maybe this is this is something
different now compared to to the to the
other situation where the kingside was
blocked as after a four and my take
giant c4 King e6 now I still have this e
5 idea so what I'm talking about
something that or maybe g5
no no this is straight lost so he must
stay
Jack take yeah this is again a clear win
five eighty three six and this gives
black very good winning chances but ok
it's a very deep so the King and Poland
came here he should really play c4 which
I think should I should be much better
in comparison I need to prevent this so
King c6 and now I don't know some normal
moves here I don't think I can can do
much can do much I've got this symbolic
advantage with the isolated pawn but
he's got the more active King so this
should probably can't cancel each other
out to a draw ok thanks for watching